okay good evening ladies and gentlemen
and welcome to tonight's planning
committee meeting my name is peter
richards and i will be chairing this
evening's meeting some housekeeping if i
may first of all uh this meeting is a
meeting in public it is not a public
meeting so please only those that are
registered to speak will be permitted to
do so at the appropriate time you'll be
introduced and asked to come forward to
one of the tables in front of us and the
microphones work if you press the button
in the middle it should turn red
and you'll be able to
speak and be heard um we will tell you
how much time you have and you'll be
able to deliver your speech and then
you'll be asked to remain for questions
um we aren't expecting any fire alarms
tonight so if one does go off please
follow us out to the car park next to
the windmill pub where we can check that
you've left the building safely before
you head off home
mobile phones please if you would turn
them off at the very least to silence i
appreciate people need to use them from
time to time so um i don't mind using
them provided they don't disturb the
flow of tonight's meeting
right let's get some introductions going
first of all so um we have committee
services we have liv liz jawaska to my
uh immediate rights we have sue mullins
our solicitor
and our planners are amy flute ella bass
sarah chadwick online we have alison
willis and to my immediate left is david
jeffries who is our planning manager
david i believe you have a statement to
make i do thank you chair my name is
david jeffrey my role is to provide
impartial advice and to assist members
in their decision taking thank you
marvelous thank you very much let's dive
in to the meeting proper first of all
apologies for absence do we have an
apologies please yes chairman you have
apologies from councillors curtis dixon
eden foreman and h sarafin this evening
thank you very much disclose of interest
members do we have any disclosures
counselor mills first please yes thanks
mr chairman um on the first application
21 stroke zero to double four five
stroke if you will um
the app can actually lives in my award
not in my uh
uh so i am known to the applicant i'll
come to this with an open mind mr
chairman
thank you lovely stuff thank you very
much anyone else with a disclosure
they'd like to make
uh just myself then on the same apple uh
application i'm a war member i've
registered to speak so i'll be removing
myself from the chair at which point
councillor kendall will be taking over
for me for that item
okay minutes are you happy with the
minutes on the 13th of april um quick
show of hands if you're all happy and
i'll sign them afterwards
everyone happy give us a wave
i'm going to take that as a yes um start
time of meetings are you happy with six
o'clock for the for the rest of the year
that's a big yes from everyone
marvellous um we are going to jumble up
the uh um the applications a little bit
if i may so
uh items seven eight nine and ten they
are application reference numbers twenty
two zero zero three three seven ful zero
zero three three eight ful zero zero
eight three four zero ful and zero zero
three four one ful is land and buildings
at the rear of jacob japonica in southam
road um
we have had no registered speakers so in
line with our constitution we are able
to delegate to officers could i plea i'm
going to propose that could have a
secondary council jennings could have a
sheriff hansel those in favor of
delegating unanimous marvelous so those
therefore have been delegated
right let's get into our first actual
item
which is
application 2102 445 f2l i need to
vacate the chair and welcome councillor
kendall to it
otherwise it'll be amy flute will be our
potential officer
right okay so it's our first application
uh very quickly this is twenty one slash
two
zero two four four five slash ful
uh land offs at michaels road cleveland
uh amy your presenting officer over to
you
thank you chairman
so the site is donated but donated by
the black dot is located within the
village of claverden a category free
local service village
the application site edge red is a green
space surrounded by existing residential
properties the site is within the
built-up area boundary the site has tpo
trees to the north and south boundaries
edged green on the plan two of these are
now proposed to be removed the land
level rises in an easterly direction the
site is outside of both conservation
areas which are edged pink on the plan
planning permission is sought for the
demolition of a single story extension
to number 10 st michaels road to form an
access into the site to facilitate the
construction of five dwellings
there have been two recent refusals on
the site the site plan and the street
scene proposals for to the two refusals
can now be seen by comparison to the
most recent reviews of application
reference um
the 2020 reference sorry the current
proposal seeks an alternative access
arrangement and has made some slight
alterations to the layout
the site
the site will be served by a new access
row taken from saint michael's road
utilizing part of number 10 st michael's
road roads plot each dwelling will have
a rear to rear relationship with the
dwellings that front st michaels road
number 10 st michael's roads existing
and proposed elevations can now be seen
these demonstrate the extent of the
demolition required to facilitate the
access road to serve the site
the proposed dwellings will be single
story a mix of two and three bedrooms
each property has a garage they will be
constructed from brick and tile with a
glazed atrium in their design
an aerial image of the site can now be
seen which demonstrates the relationship
of the site with the neighboring
properties and their gardens which
surround the site
the tpo trees that line the north and
south boundaries can be seen
the existing access of st michael's road
that serves church field close can be
seen and the new access will run
parallel to this
so the existing access that serves
churchfield close is now being shown the
single story side extension at number 10
st michaels road is the part of the
property which is to be demolished to
make way for the new access
the proposed new access will run
parallel to church for your closest
access this image is taken looking
southwesterly from churchfield close
back to st michael's road and number 10
is this property on the left
so this image is taken within the site
looking in a northwesterly direction
where the land level gently falls away
the trees within the center of the site
are to be removed and they are not
covered by the tpo
the site southern boundary and trees
that form parts of the group tpo can now
be seen
and finally the site's northern boundary
and trees that form part of that greek
tpo can also now be seen and it is from
this boundary where two will be removed
chairman it is considered that the
proposal does not amount to limited
infill and thus amounts to inappropriate
development within the greenbelt other
harm has been identified in terms of the
backlin nature of the site and the
cumulative harm that arises as a result
of the proposed design and layout it is
also considered that there will be harm
to trees covered by a tree protection
order
chairman it is recommended that planning
permission is refused for the reasons as
detailed within the committee report
please also note that there are some
updates on the update sheet which
includes an update to a reason for
refusal thank you
that's fantastic thank you amy uh we
have two registered speakers so we'll go
to our first speaker this evening mr
gary moss agent for the applicant please
good evening right so as as usual i
think you know the routine you've been
here before so you've got three minutes
i'll give you a warning at 30 final 30
seconds if that's okay and if you remain
seated for any questions in that case
it's over to you
of course
sorry it's catching that
is that all right okay up to you
um thank you chairman members um
negotiating this scheme has taken a
considerable amount of time and been
working to try and address the concerns
of your officers
as a result of these negotiations the
scheme has been amended to include two
and three bed bungalows in lieu of
previously schemed for houses
this change has not only helped some
technical issues which i'll come to but
also provides an opportunity for people
to move on thus releasing family homes
in order to support the local housing
market for claverdon itself
despite the amendments officers
obviously have maintained reasons for
refusal
reasons one and two green belt and
cramped development
in terms of green belt the officer
accepts that the site constitutes
infilling
and that in the context of claverden
five units would be limited
objection is only raised on green
backgrounds in terms of the size scale
bulk and spread of development in
reaching this conclusion the officer
refers to two appeal decisions
unfortunately these are not comparable
as they both relate to the redevelopment
of a single dwelling and or garden land
and are situated on the edge of their
respective settlements in contrast we
have a site
open
situated within the centre of the
village of claverden
it is disappointing that an appeal at
snitterfield which is actually far more
comparable in terms of the number of
units and the site area has not been
covered in the committee report
that was allowed on appeal and has got
very similar characteristics to the site
to add further context on these matters
this site is around 0.4 hectares and
comprises 5 units a density of 12
dwellings per hectare
the equivalent area to the south
alongside
michael's road has six dwellings and is
around 11 dwellings per hectare and
furthermore to the north along park
drive there's about eight or nine units
and that's around 13 dreadings per
hectare clearly these are comparable and
the development is comparable with its
surrounding neighbours
and not as we would argue constitute
inappropriate development in the green
belt or would it have any adverse impact
on the character and appearance of the
area
the other reason for use were relating
to the root protection areas of trees
and overshadowing
the application was submitted with a
detailed agricultural report which has
been updated
this concludes that development on this
site would not adversely impact those
trees and would not cause any
unacceptable overshadowing impact
more importantly the client did never
challenge the imposition of the area tpo
because the scheme was always designed
to ensure that the perimeter tree
planting would be retained albeit
managed managed inappropriately 30
seconds
in terms of car parking
each unit has the cried standards the
concern is over visitor parking
although this is a cooler stack of five
dwellings on a road that is five meters
wide therefore on street parking could
easily be
accompanied and not cause harm to
highways highways are not objected
notwithstanding the social economic
benefits of the scheme the developer has
a history of promoting green cadentials
in building and promotes the use of
photovoltaic air source heat pumps to
remove the need for gas boilers
in conclusion the scheme represents a
sustainable form of development
compliant with the development plan and
we respectfully ask members to grant
planning commission some addicted
conditions in the completion of a
section 106 agreement thank you thank
you
okay any questions from the committee
please
yes counselor mills
thanks mr chairman hi gary good to see
you um
another report is is is based on um
on the tpo and green belt um
and you always mention about the um
the trees um
not being harmed but um
how they mitigated the um the harm to
the
to the roots and the trees what's been
done or can you explain to me
um
the agricultural report obviously goes
into far more detail than the south but
basically the development itself has
been laid out so that where there is
incursion into the root protection areas
that's predominantly
hard standing the access road
there is an incursion on the garages but
that's going to be mini piled wrath
foundation so again minimum disturbance
to the root protection areas
um these trees haven't really been
touched so there is as part of the
scheme also management of some of the
trees in terms of crown lifting
but this is all general management
maintenance of the existing trees so
it's all perfectly um appropriate
agricultural practices on a site that
has been fairly neglected for some time
so we're confident
um the no dig construction and the
methods imposed as per that report there
should be no damage or harm caused to
those trees
um let's understand that two trees are
going to be removed is that correct
that's correct yeah the latest update
the two trees in the very
on the on the aerial photo in that
corner there there's two small trees
category c trees
um
are to be removed in order to um enable
the garage to plot
five um to be constructed but um out of
all the trees under that area tpo that
they're the only ones being removed
sorry are there tpos on those
they're covered under the area tpo so
right with an area tpo it's not specific
trees it's just a blanket area tpo so
within that you would look at the
individual trees and the agricultural
specialist looking at that as eating
those trees as being acceptable for
removal
what is it i mean i
i did go
and look at well i couldn't look at the
side huh um
i couldn't go and look inside um
what is it being used for at the moment
the that site
yeah my understanding is it was a former
orchard
as a few orchard trees left which are
being removed as part of the scheme but
they weren't covered by the tpo other
than that it's just an open um area of
land within the village so they're not
residents you don't know if residents
use it or not or anything it's it's
private land it's not any communal i of
course yeah thanks
okay any other questions from the
committee please
that case mr moss thank you very much
for your time tonight much appreciated
thank you for giving things wiped down
oh we can move to our next speaker then
council richards ward member if you want
to come up as well
welcome i think you also know the
routine
thank you got five minutes over to you
thank you chairman um
it goes without saying i think i agree
with uh what has just been said by our
agent short of rehearsing all of that
gain for you i thought i'd focus on two
issues that i consider to be uh
important this the first one being green
belt issue you'll see in your report um
my support has come particularly in
favor of that in to my mind this is very
much limited infill and
i've come to that conclusion by
comparing it to a site in another
village of mine snitterfield
i'm sure many of you remember sitting on
this committee when we uh discussed
appleton house and land behind that
for ten houses i grant you the land was
much bigger uh probably twice the size
but it was for twice the number of
houses that went to appeal we had
refused that went to appeal and was one
um it was considered to be limited
infill i've drawn comparisons from that
we've got half the size of land half the
number of homes to my mind that does
reinforce the point that this should be
considered limited in phil
the second point um specifically is
about the car parking i know some
residents have had some concerns and and
frustrations about the uh the access um
we have no objection now from our
highways officers um uh it is then down
to the parking we have ten uh parking
spaces uh provided on site um that
leaves us with one visitor space i
believe there to be plenty of space to
accommodate a visitor car parking within
the site but as we've heard from the the
agent uh on michael's road there is more
than sufficient space to cover that uh
one visitor space so to my mind there is
adequate parking it does fit within
our spd and our required parking
requirements
i would say to you now it's up to you to
decide whether you think based on what
you've seen and the pictures that have
been provided to you whether you believe
the design of these properties and the
scale of them are appropriate for that
site i believe that they are
but i'm not the decision maker
that's up to you
thank you
thank you do you have any questions for
the ward member
don't rush at once
or at all in that case thank you very
much you're free to step down
okay committee let's go two points of
clarification anybody got any questions
for the honor officers councillor crump
thank you mr chairman um amy um
the update in the uh update report about
the trees
it says two further trees will need to
be removed t8 and t9
um so chrome can i ask you to adjust the
mic because you're not picking up very
clearly all right thank you might be a
bonus
[Laughter]
um yes i'll start again sorry i mean um
yeah just
regarding the update sheet with the uh
version three by cotswold wildlife
surveys which is saying that two further
trees will need to be removed t8 t9
which are part of their tpo group
group tpo
so can i confirm
will that make four trees removed
so um
as of today and we were advised that two
of the trees within the group tpo will
be removed whereas until today we were
aware that no trees under the group tpo
were to be removed the only trees which
were going to be removed were the trees
which i state within um the officer
report which are um
they're in the center of the site um so
there's two additional trees to be
removed which are covered by the tpo so
two are tpo'ed into an optical um let me
just confirm the number of how many
other trees are to be removed i can't
remember
bear with me
so
if you bear with me one moment i'll just
go to the um
tree survey and then i can um
clarify that
so
so t8 t9 which a tpo are to be removed
and then t
22 to 24 and t26 so that's a total of
um six trees
okay
any other points yes council jennings
is there any definition anywhere which
um for
limited i mean
obviously there's limited and unlimited
that's what you could say and is there
anywhere which actually has a definition
on that
so within my office of report you will
see that it clearly states the term
limited infill is not defined within the
mppf or the planning practice guidance
and whether development can be
considered to represent limited
infilling in a
in a village or a settlement or anywhere
is a matter of fact and degree and it's
planning to judgement so purely
this will come down to what we regard as
the subject to us
okay and then sorry another further
question
um
policy cs5 it seeks to resist the loss
of trees which are of high public
immunity value
as this is on private land how does that
work out and is that of
is this not open to the public is it the
the trees obviously are covered by a t
tree protection order which is to ensure
that
they they contribute to the to the
character of the area um and obviously
they have been um
tpo'ed for a reason to ensure that their
immunity and their character and the
contribution that they make is retained
it retained
so someone looking at their back window
can see them and appreciate them
yes i think it's fair to say that a tpo
tree offers immunity beyond its
immediate boundaries it would offer
immunity to the people who live on
neighbouring roads and it would form a
verdant backdrop to their own dwellings
they would get glimpse views of it in
the area it contributes positively to
the character
and hence the tp
great thank you very much thank you
we've got council mills next thanks
michelle um
out of interest um
the bungalows themselves are they um um
i mean are they heat sourced pumpkin i
know are they
up to date with the environmentally
friendly aspect
can we
because we haven't got any any um
sort of images of what these look like
have we
say any artist impression that's what
i'm looking for the
they have um a climate change checklist
has been submitted with the proposal um
and
um the development will have water birth
recycling points permeable paving secure
cycle storage and ev charging points
the climate change checklisters also
make reference to
the use of solar panels or ground air
source heat pumps but no detail has been
submitted at this stage so if members
were minded to
recommend approval then obviously that's
detail which we can seek through
condition
right so
at the moment they can have heat sort
the suggestion has been made that that's
what the properties would have but i
don't have that detail
at this stage which is why we could
condition that to secure it
right okay thank you okay council
fleming
just a quick follow-on from what council
mills was saying and he's going to have
sort of permeable driveways and things
like that because in that enclosed space
i just wondered about water runoff and
stuff like that really
um so
the there's reference to the use of
permeable drive driveways and that's
something which could be conditioned if
members were mine mindful to approve to
secure that okay thank you follow on
question if i can um
there's two previous applications for
this have been refused and it says in
here that they don't differ is there any
fundamental differences between any of
what's already been
submitted and refused as to what we're
looking at today um so the 2019
application as you can see um the
dwellings were um two-story um so then
the the later application in 2020 and
that reduced the scheme um
down and the differences between this
scheme and that the scheme that was
previously refused is that there's been
alterations to the access and there's
been some tweaks to
the the layout in terms of the garaging
for some of the plots has altered but
but predominantly the design of the
dwellings is the same as what was
previously submitted and refused
i would remind committee though we are
bound by what's before us tonight rather
than pre you know that's okay councilor
mills but that they are single story but
not the other one was
two stories
and what is the difference in the height
um so the proposal before us they are
single story um they have maximum height
of 6.3 meters i can't comment on the
difference in the heights for the last
application i don't have that before me
they're single yeah okay thank you right
no more points for clarification
okay should we go to the debate who
would like to kick us off on this
anyone at all
counselor adam
thanks um i i take
the support of the ward member and i can
see that the applicant has tried to
address some of the concerns but on
balance i think the green belt issue is
and and the way in which the officers
interpret interpreted this
sits with my reading as well and that
actually the
openness of the green belt is
is something we really do need to
protect and that's kind of a principle
that i
i know we've supported before so at the
moment i'm inclined to go along with the
officer's recommendation um
i'm happy to
propose that but i'm also intrigued to
see what everyone else has to say so
i'll uh
probe that is that a proposal uh yes
thank you council jennings
i'll probably differ to you on slightly
off on this
that and i certainly regard this as
as
as infill whether it's
limited infill or unlimited infill is is
probably a different thing and i can
i think with the volume which is in
there at the moment which is being
proposed at the moment is probably
it's it's very close to being too much
um
if it was
if they're
less properties more car parking i don't
really like the idea that any visitors
car parking is going to be on site
michael's road that's that's a walk
um
it's
i'd be more comfortable
um and more inclined to support this
application if there are if there's a
smaller volume
um and
something could be done with the car
parking but those are my thoughts
thank you councillor mills
thanks thanks mr chairman um i'm i'm
just reading well i have obviously read
the um
officer's report um
you know there's no harms of
conservation here it says here
the separation
distances are 48 meters
30 meters
um
so it quite some distance from
from the the other gardens of the uh
of the other um properties um and there
was a mishmash of properties of designs
around there um
i mean this
refusal appears to be based on tpo and
the green belt well the um
the agent has said that they
had a report and there could be little
or no harm to the um to the trees when
this um
if this development goes ahead so um
they are mr chairman my thoughts thank
you thank you council mills council
crumb
thank you mr
i'm happy to um second council adam's
proposal to refuse um for several
reasons
um i don't think he is limited in phil
due to the scale and in the bulk of the
development
i think councilor mills
might not have read the update or might
have misunderstood the update i'm trying
to be careful against the mills i'm in
throwing distance i have read it and i
think it says there will be
two trees that will have to be removed
that got tpo's on
um so i think there is some is harm to
the tpo's
uh trees
um i don't think there are very special
circumstances
that overcome the green building in the
greenbelt area
and with that uh housing land supply
five years housing land supply light
point four two years we haven't got a
prison need for these houses
i think the scheme has got merit but i
don't think it's quite right and if it's
not quite right in my opinion it's wrong
so i will not be supported i will be
supporting council adam's
proposal to refuse the application
for the reasons i've just mentioned and
supporting council adams reasons as well
okay
council fleming
yeah my thoughts are uh
this parking in the next road because
there's not enough room for visitors to
park outside the houses and there's also
issues with the refuge collection having
to be taken all the way up and onto some
like
some michael's road so
i'll uh i'll not be i'll be supporting
the officer's recommendation at this
stage
thank you um i'll add my thoughts
broadly in line with the majority of the
committee i think on this
i'm not i don't have any fundamental
problems with you know something there
one day but it's this certainly is not
right and for my for me that i'll be
i'll be going along with the office
recommendation as well right if we've
all spoken um we have a proposal that's
been hooked for us to refuse and it's
been seconded has anybody else got
anything to say
that case let's go to the vote all those
in favor of refusal please show
therefore the committee resolves to
refuse application reference twenty one
slash zero two four four five slash f ul
and we move to item six and i'll hand
back over to council richards
okay cancer kendall thank you very much
for that members uh if i could draw your
attention back to the room um
while sat in the back there i was
struggling to hear and i know some
members of the public are struggling to
hear as well so we have had our
microphones reset recently um i think
the volume probably needs to turn up but
unfortunately we don't have the facility
to do that here so if you could please
speak up into your microphones that will
help both us and members of the public
who are listening
um okay excuse me let's move on to our
next application which is item six and
that is application reference
21027225 obviously pastures our
presentation officer is eleanor bass
owner over to you
thank you chair
this application is a full planning
application for revisions to the extent
of garden land associated with the
dwelling including the creation of a
designated landscape and ecology own
along with a provision of a fence tennis
court
the application site lies approximately
1.8 kilometers to the east of the edge
of stratfor town and is identified by
the black dot on the plan
the site is located within the open
countryside and is at the end of a row
of five dwellings the site area is
outlined in red with the green circles
and the green dotted area showing trees
subject of a tpo recently served on the
site to the west of the site runs a
public footpath
here we have the red line area plan that
has been submitted with the application
with the proposed tennis court to the
north east of the dwelling
is a more detailed site plan which shows
the extent of the garden land proposed
as part of the application coloured in
blue
this plan provides some more context to
the proposals with the plan on the left
showing the existing dwelling and lawful
cursilage of the dwelling along with the
tennis court and outbuildings which have
recently been confirmed as being
permitted development within the
existing garden
the plan to the right shows the
proposals under this current application
with the area of land to the north to
change use from agricultural to garden
land with a tennis court now proposed on
this part of the land
the hatched area is being proposed to be
sewn with wildflower and become a
managed area through a landscape and
ecological management plan
we now have three aerial views of the
site
the 1999 and 2017 photographs show the
dwelling with its lawful cartilage along
with a hedgerow and boundary line to the
north which delineates the cartilage
from the agricultural land
the latest photo from 2021 shows the
removal of this boundary line of hedge
and trees with a new fence directed
further to the north and two goal posts
shown on this area of land which now
appears to be used as garden
now have some photos of the site
the top two photos show the area of land
proposed as garden land which appears to
already be in use for residential
purposes with it being closely known and
with two goal posts cited on it
members will note the new boundary fence
in the background of these photos
the bottom left photo is looking back
towards the house with the lands now
open to the dwelling and the existing
rear boundary hedge removed
the right hand photo is looking towards
the treed area that is lawful garden
land and where the tennis court and
outbuilding have been permitted under
the lawful development certificate
the left-hand photo shows in more detail
this treed area of the garden which is
subject to a tpo on the right we are
stood on the road with the application
site to the left
members will note the trees on this land
which again have recently been protected
by a tree preservation order
there are a couple of updates to the
application which are detailed on the
update sheet
the proposed change of use of
agricultural
land to garden land along with the
creation of a tennis court is considered
to be contrary to the requirements of
policy as10 and would also lead to harm
to the character of the area by virtue
of encroachment to the countryside
therefore the recommendation is to
refuse the application for the reasons
set out on page 32 of the agenda
thank you very much we will call our
first speaker on this item who is mr
blackwell our applicant and i believe we
have mr goodall as well to answer any
questions if that is that right
please grab a seat whichever one you
want to sit at
wherever you're comfortable
number splater i'm assuming you're gonna
have three minutes grab what you need to
grab
that's absolutely fine
can i just ask we've got some oh yeah
so you'll have three minutes um we have
slides for you could you have you got a
signal you can give us you just give it
a nod or something like that you're
going to do that perfect um
if i'll give you a third second one
before we end and then obviously if you
can stay seated for questions afterwards
press in the middle it should turn red
and then whenever you're ready it's over
to you okay
me and my family are keen sports people
and it's always been our ambition to
build a tennis court that we can make
available for us and local friends for
all of our physical and mental
well-being
we had two options when we assess the
feasibility of where to place a court
one to build at the end of our garden or
two to seek permission to build it in
our paddock we never contemplated
building a court at the end of our
garden as this would involve removing
the bulk of the trees which was not an
option for us
the paddock to the rear of the property
is banded on all sides by three meter
high hedging and there is no access to
it other than through our driveway it is
therefore effectively landlocked for its
permitted use and only two acres is
arguably too small to be effectively
used for agriculture
we therefore submitted the current
application to do the following one
offer a land swap for the land in the
paddock where we are looking to place
the court in return for taking the land
under the trees at the end of our garden
out of our residential cartilage and
designating it as agricultural or
amenity land as the committee is aware
the residential cartilage can be decided
by condition and we have submitted
revised plans although not presented
which show an exact like-for-like swap
resulting in no loss of land satisfying
policy as-10
two to introduce a length to invest
further in the proposed landscape area
to commit to maintaining the trees but
also increasing the biodiversity in this
area by the introduction of bird and bat
boxes and the sowing of wild flowers to
encourage the local insect population
under threat
three to introduce new tree species in
our hedgerows around the paddock to
further increase local biodiversity
in lieu of 0.1 being satisfied we are
aware that the benefits of 0.2 and 3
needed to outweigh the other
considerations of the potential impact
of the court
given the likelihood swap of the land
and that the court is not visible from
any point outside of our boundary we
believe the benefits outweigh the impact
the slides show how we have high hedging
and dense foliage on our boundaries with
only the upper parts of our property
visible outside of them we have also
introduced further new hedging which
when mature will further hide the court
there is a footpath 282 meters from the
edge of our rear boundary which is a
further 68 meters from the end of the
proposed court but as per this slide no
part of our garden is visible
the surface of our court would be a
synthetic grass the chain link
elevations would have a reduced fencing
height of one meters
sorry the side chain linked elevations
would have a reduced fencing height of
one meter and the end elevations would
be 2.75 meters lower than our hedge
height a lower height of two meters is
also agreeable
it has never been our intention to
remove the trees in our garden but in
fact to commit to maintaining them to a
high standard we were therefore
immensely disappointed and shocked to
receive the tpo which we have formally
objected to the tpo is to prevent us
removing the trees under the ldc but we
only submitted the ldc after
encouragement for the from the lpa to
create a full back position the tpo
prevents us from maintaining the trees
and has a material impact on the value
of our property
thank you
perfect that's about spiciest wrap up
but clearly
you're well within time
members do we have any questions for
either our applicant or his
agent
castle jennings
you think
you're
seeking to
take about 2
100 square meters of agricultural land
into your garden
you had a tennis court it's only about
444
um square metres
it seems to be like a bit of a
discrepancy there so
why didn't you just apply for 544 square
meters so
slight oversight to be honest um but
i would advise that with the the
information we submitted um and requests
to be included as part of the update did
demonstrate that
the intentions of our clients are quite
easily achievable with a like flight
swap
um we've amended the uh the curtis to
show that but
as um we've also intimated this boundary
could be controlled by condition as well
and we're quite happy to detail that so
that
we're members minded to approve we can
ensure that the um
the bias is either equal or even in the
agricultural lands favor
there's no intention to land grab
essentially yeah sorry just to reiterate
that um
we're we're perfectly happy to to agree
to reduce
curtid swap um which we have presented
or have submitted to the planets but it
hasn't been presented today because of
timing
and we're aware that the committee can
condition that
um in respect to the tennis court to be
honest we'd be very happy just to submit
that
if the if the committee was minded to
accept
so i think what i'm trying to say is
we're very committed to maintaining
these trees
but we're also willing to be very
flexible on
the
um the size of the cartilage
but with the committee conditioning that
okay any other questions from our
members please
no in that case mr blackwell mr gold
thank you very much for your time
contribution assuming and while you're
finally making your way back to your
seat so call forward our next speaker
who is councillor rolfe councillor good
evening and welcome
thank you chair
you i'm sure understand uh the process
tonight you'll have five minutes i'll
give you 30 second warning you can use
as much or as little as that five
minutes as you like whenever you're
comfortable and ready it's over to you
it's top left counselor bills um
if the committee feel that they are not
in a position to approve without sight
of the additional information as noted
on the update sheet then we respectfully
suggest that the application is deferred
i'm happy to continue with my speech
however the proposed update would have
made a lot more sense to the committee
but sadly it was not allowed to be
presented
if you were to go and see um the setting
of this house and land you will
understand that there's absolutely no
intention of the applicants destroying
any of this beautiful countryside with
its gorgeous trees why would they they
are as passionate about biodiversity as
anyone i know
the tree report which the applicant was
encouraged to have done and which the
applicant paid for was used by the
planning authority without their
permission as the basis for the tpo
this has led to some inaccuracies of the
report there are no oak trees or grade a
trees within the cartilage of the
property they are located outside of the
applicant's ownership and therefore
should have no consideration in this
discussion if the application is
approved and the land under the trees
will be physically removed from the
applicant's domestic cartilage by
offense
it is therefore incorrect that the land
would remain as lawful domestic
cartilage as there would be no ability
for the applicant to exercise his
permitted development rights or develop
any structures on this land
both of these issues are misleading
now that some of the trees have been
tpo'ed by this authority it means that
the applicant can't go anywhere near his
own trees to look after them and this
will now mean that no one
will be able to look after them the
applicant is in fact appealing against
tpos as he wants to be able to protect
and look after the trees himself at his
own cost
the land referred to as agricultural
land is owned and used by the owner as
garden land which they maintain
regularly this land has not been used as
agricultural land to their knowledge for
over 15 years in fact the land is
landlocked and there is no access to it
other than via going through the house
they want to put a tennis court with a
see-through mesh load fencing around it
and they are happy for it not to be
permanent fixture with removable
removable fencing this will not be seen
by anyone from the road and the footpath
is behind a tall hedge over 300 meters
away that you saw a picture earlier they
don't want to spoil their own view by
putting something which doesn't fit in
with the setting of their own house no
neighbours have ejected and all the
neighbors have been asked
the owners have also offered to the
neighbours the use of the court this
increasing well health and well-being
the owners are intending to put more
trees into the surrounding area this
will increase biodiversity
if required the applicant has stated
that he would concede certain permitted
development rights on the land swapped
into the domestic cartilage to allay any
concerns
you have of future development on this
land over and above the proposed tennis
courts and he would give the equivalent
amount of land back which could be
conditioned
i would respect respectfully ask that
this committee allows the see-through
temporary structure of a tennis court
with no hard standing to go ahead
frankly i don't think we should be
wasting anyone's time by bringing this
back and involving more work on the
planner's behalf and the committee's
behalf thank you for your time
that's right thank you very much members
do we have any questions for our ward
member please cancel crump
good afternoon councillor off um can i
just clarify something
did you say that there was some
agricultural land that hadn't been used
for agricultural purposes for 15 years
but was being used as garden land
it has been used as garden land for uh
to their knowledge the owner's knowledge
and the previous owner's knowledge for
well over 15 years probably longer
thank you
any other questions for a ward member
please
council jennings
sorry just on that point uh the fencing
seems to have disappeared from in the
photos
do you know
i know i should probably ask this to
when the applicant
but i just wondered whether
uh when those fences came down
sorry um
i'm going to stop you there we really
shouldn't be having a conversation
between the two of you when the question
was directed at you
i appreciate you i appreciate you trying
to get an answer um
this is the question should have been
put beforehand okay so i do have the
answer if i'm allowed to give it to uh
you can answer the question that has
been put okay
so as part um the applicant had planning
permission to extend his house and a
part of that planning commission
permission he was allowed to move some
of the hedging and some of the fencing
okay
okay members any other questions for our
world member at this point
no in that case canceroff thank you very
much your time contribution
right we'll move into points of
clarification i think i can think of one
of them already council jennings would
you like to ask it
about the fence lines please
do we have any idea when that might have
been in that application sorry could you
just um repeat the question i didn't
hear it
yes sorry when were the fence lines uh
moved and was it part of the
any clarification on a previous planning
okay and
so
this um
slide shows um in
2017
um it appeared that that boundary um
did exist
um and then 2020 that fence line has
been um removed and that boundary has
removed and
as part of the um
previous application to extend the house
and the red line didn't include this
area to the north it was around
the dwelling so it didn't include an
extended cartilage in that application
you might also
heed the planning history shown on page
26 of the agenda shows um
sometime in the middle of 2019 a
planning permission granted for
two-story extension to the rear of the
property that sort of tallies with the
aerial images you're seeing there so i
would expect some time towards the end
of 2019
beginning of 2020.
okay
uh council mills first please
thanks um german um sit on on the trees
the
both got tpos on these two trees
and when was the tpo
put on
thank you
so
um there are two individual tree
preservation orders
to the front of the site which is shown
by these two individual green circles
and there is also a group tree
preservation order
which is shown by the green
dotted line which includes
13 trees
the
tpo
was served on the 28th of march this
year
thank you
council crump please
again i think you might get where i'm
coming from this one i mentioned um
the agricultural land
sorry oh i get request yeah i mentioned
the um i spoke to the woodman about the
agricultural land that hadn't been used
potentially for 15 years
and was potentially being used apologies
are far slight misunderstood but was
potentially being used as garden land
gonna get going getting some nods
does that mean if it's been used for
garden land for 15 years
it
refers to garden land from agricultural
land or does it still require an
official
change of designation of use
so under a lawful development
certificate um
you can apply
to essentially prove that land has been
used for domestic purposes for a period
of ten years
um you'll see from the planning history
that they did actually apply for lawful
development certificates um
in 2021 um but that application was
withdrawn
um and
i believe that was probably on the basis
that there wasn't evidence that that
area of land has been used for a period
of 10 years
thank you for that that was yeah
obviously worth asking the question and
then obviously i hadn't got the
background so yeah that's helpful thank
you
carsogenics
that
agricultural land um i'm just trying to
get an understanding of this is there
anything to stop someone if they do have
a field
cutting the grass
low and playing football on it if it is
agricultural land
or is there some sort of definition that
if they build on it or actually sort of
dig any of it up then it changes
because if you had a field and you
decided you wanted to play
i don't know football or perhaps put
some lines on there and play tennis on
it but it was just still a field
would that be is that acceptable or is
that not acceptable how is that policed
how
tell me about agricultural rights
so i think and it's obviously a matter
of fact and degree
and how potentially intensive
a site is used um
if
that land is being used intensively for
domestic purposes
um with um
tables chairs domestic paraphernalia
sheds washing lines etc and
then
that is probably showing that it is
being used for domestic purposes but i
think it
you're getting into the questions of
lawful development certificates and
fact and degree in in that assessment um
and it can be quite
i'm just trying to sort of get my head
around how the rules as it were
um so in effect if they were to take
their goal post office when they use it
once a fortnight
it's
it's falling into that gray area isn't
it
that's great
yeah
okay any other questions or points of
clarification to our officers at this
stage council trump sorry about this
again um it's just about the obviously
the amended plan came in on the 17th of
may
um
how long would it normally take to
assess an amended plan
roughly
i think we'd want to um go
go out for a consultation with it again
so that's a period of 21 days um and um
obviously officers would have to be um
making a full consideration of those
proposals so it's it's not a necessarily
a quick turnaround we'd want to make
sure that
everybody was notified and consultees
are made aware of it
i think i would also add that the
council is not under an obligation to
accept an amendment to a planning
application once it's in process
the plan which members have heard
described um
changes some of the fundamental aspects
of this proposal arguably it takes it
away from the application which was
originally made to this authority
the more appropriate course of action
may well be for the applicant to
withdraw the proposal
and have it
resubmitted with an amended plan rather
than to have an amendment under this
particular application
so as i say members are under no
obligation to consider it if they do not
feel like they need to
okay
have we finished with our points of
clarification for officers i think we
have
council adam do you have a question
okay we're moving to debate and i think
council adam would like to kick us off
to
well i think uh councillor crump's
getting out it was actually something i
was thinking before um counselor rolf
spoke was actually that
what it seems that they've submitted as
an
amendment seems to be addressing some of
the concerns they've been referencing it
a lot but obviously we can't see it i
was thinking of proposing a deferral so
that it could be properly
assessed by our officers i appreciate
what david's saying about
maybe it's better to withdraw and
resubmit but
i'm sort of trying to work out the most
expedient way and
you know the
least cost to the council as well um to
do that
if that's something that other members
can think
think is
agreeable i'd propose that we defer it
so that could be assessed as an
amendment
okay i'm going to take that as a
proposal to defer for the reasons that
you've given um we'll open up for debate
for the rest of the members and we'll
see where we go so who would like to
come in next council jennings
you know
i think that they say this
i think the application's wrong it
shouldn't
it seems to have been chopped and
changed and i
i would have thought that they would
have probably withdrawn it and put a new
application in that would have been to
me the logical thing
um
i think
if they'd put in for
544 square meters
the size of a tennis court
um
and therefore the other thousand five
hundred would have remained in
in agricultural use i would have been a
lot more comfortable
um
and
whether they play football on it on the
rest of it again it's nothing to do with
this
but if it's been for a small this 544
square meters and offsetting it against
the rest then i would have been a lot
more comfortable
my thoughts
thank you very much council jennings
anyone else like to come in
before i do
okay i'll check my two points worth in
now um
it's pretty clear from what we've heard
that the applicant is under the
impression that the land that he's
putting forward is in fact garden land
however the council's version of it is
that it's not there is a deep amount of
confusion over that
from what i can gather having read the
update sheet and heard what's been said
the information that is waiting to be
come in or waiting to be reviewed
will help to
help us to get a better understanding of
that
i personally am a little bit
uncomfortable making a decision on
something that has so many different
aspects to it without clear evidence and
information
for me to make that decision i'm minded
to support your and second your uh
proposal to defer
we can then obviously go back out
through the the the appropriate process
in order to be able to then consider it
and that does of course leave the
applicant
to be able to withdraw or maintain the
application through that process my
personal feeling is that is the best
thing to do at this stage so i'm
seconding that if anyone else has
anything i'd like to say by all means do
so and put your hand up now otherwise we
will move to a vote
okay in that case the proposal is to
defer for the reasons given can i have a
show of hands for those in favor of
deferral please
that is unanimous so committee have
therefore resolved to defer application
21 0 2 7 2 22 f u l
right
let's move into our final item of the
evening
this is item number 11 application
references are 21 0 3 9 5 2 very and 22
0 0 5 5 2 very 22 welcome road um our
presenting officer will be sarah
chadwick just as soon as she's ready and
comfortable so sarah as soon as you're
comfortable and no need to rush as soon
as you're ready it's over to you
thank you chairman the applications
before members tonight are two section
73 applications both of which seek to
vary condition to the plan's condition
of planning commission reference
2102869 ful for the erection of
replacement dwelling they seek to amend
the external facing materials design
height and overall footprint of the
dwelling the application site is on
welcome road which is within the
building area boundary of stratfor naval
and can be seen outlined by the red line
on this plan
the site is within the stratfor naval
conservation area which is denoted by
the pink line on this plan
the dotted and solid green lines uh to
the east of the property and the north
and the south
denote tree preservation orders on an
adjacent site
here we see an image of the original
dwelling at 22 elkham road
this slide shows the elevations as
approved under the full application on
the left for the replacement dwelling
with the proposed elevations subject to
the two applications before members
tonight shown on the right
the proposed alterations include the
wider use of render on the front
elevation an increase in the height and
width of the right forward projecting
gable increase in height of the porch
eaves and
the porch and the poor jeeps and
amendments the architectural detailing
of the dwelling
chairman the design alterations proposed
under the variation of condition 2 on
both applications are considered
cumulatively to result in material harm
to the character of the street scene and
wider conservation area with no public
benefit identified
the changes are considered to materially
diminish the quality of the development
as originally approved contrary to
paragraph 135 of the mppf
the recommendation is therefore to
refuse both the applications for the
reasons
detailed on pages 1881 of your agenda
there are no updates thank you thank you
very much sarah we will move to our
first speaker who is gary moss our
agents carry come on down
what's your name and where did you come
from
so gary i think you know you know the
drill three minutes i'll give you a 30
second morning whenever you're ready you
got some slides yeah there's just a
couple of slides we'll get the slides up
and once they're ready and you're ready
it's over to you okay
okay
yeah that's right um sorry thank you
chairman thank you members um as you
would just recall from the officer's
presentation and the image on screen
planning permission was granted for a
replacement dwelling that dwelling has
been implemented on site and is now the
starting point for assessment of this
very application not the previous
property so just to clarify that point
um in terms of the size this has come
about by the need to actually increase
the internal dimensions of the double
garage
that internal dimension has increased by
0.8 meters which has resulted in the
width increase and also the slight
increase in that right gable as pointed
out by the officer
that change is due to really comply with
the council's own sbd guidance in terms
of internal parking arrangements no
other reason
in terms of the actual size of the
building
um
this is on a large plot the one of the
largest plots on this part of welcome
road
it remains 20 to 30 meters wide and the
actual property is comparable in width
and height to those other properties
albeit those are on much smaller
locations in terms of plot width
in terms of design the change is minimal
um the biggest being obviously the use
of render rather than the brickwork
but on this point if we can look at the
second slide um you'll see that there is
a diverse range of properties along
welcome road and to reinforce that point
i just want to take some
quotes from your officers dealing with
various applications to reinforce that
point so a number 25 application 1303
169 states the street scene is made up
of a large number of detached dwellings
of varying sizes and architectural
styles eras of build at number 21 within
the street scene there is a variety of
dwellings in terms of their size and
design with a mixture of modern
bungalows through to larger traditional
houses that have been converted into
flats from number 17 the site is located
within the conservation area the
character in the immediate area is
varied with no single established design
of property generally speaking the
properties in the immediate area are
relatively large modern and they're
equally large platform part of the
character of the tree-lined street
i also note that the ward member
actively supports this application and
that the town council raised no
objection
in conclusion taking into account the
approved scheme these changes are
considered minor and would not create a
discordant design and will be wholly in
keeping with the character and
appearance of the street scene and the
wider conservation area
however
although the client is promoting the
scheme that's before you
they would be willing to accept the use
of more brick work over render if
members feel that this would be more
appropriate in allowing the development
a condition to secure materials could
be imposed and will be accepted by the
applicant
if required thank you very much
thank you very much gary um council
james has a question for you
it's on the opposite side of the road
um and i believe it's
about two properties down here if you
just go the plan should hopefully
uh so it's the second yeah it's not
directly opposites the one below the one
directly opposite the site
any other questions for our agents
cancer adam
thanks uh
just on the
carriage you seem to
giving the the size as justification
the size requirement of the garage is
justification for enlarging it but
that's obviously going to have an impact
on the rest of the building because
there's accommodation above why
why wasn't the original garage the right
size when it was submitted
um
i can only assume it was an oversight on
behalf of the architect of whether he
was aware of the spd requiring the
internal garage dimensions
and i can only assume it was error in
that basis
cancer change i see your hand got for a
second one
no
okay
no problem any anyone else with another
question
no in that case mr musk thank you very
much your time contributions this
evening
okay we'll move to the final speaker of
this evening who is council jefferson
who sadly has been uh called down to
london today on council business
he has provided me with a statement he
very kindly provided that yesterday in
fact so i will read that to you now if i
may
these are the words obviously of
counselor jefferson
welcome road is in my ward this is a
road i'm familiar with
before composing this statement i walk
the road again specifically to visit
this site
i'm not going to comment on the details
because i lack the professional
knowledge to do so
on some of what i see as rather
fundamental and clearly observable
issues i feel the need to make my views
clear which is why i'm supporting this
application
although welcome road is part of a
conservation area the housing mix could
best be described as varied and eclectic
to me no one pattern predominates
therefore from a conservation area point
of view i think it is difficult to
object to the proposal
furthermore the proposed development is
set well back from the street so its
impact on the street scene is minimized
the plot at 22 slopes the plot 22 slopes
quite significantly away from the road
so the proposed development is far less
prominent in terms of street scene than
may otherwise be the case
the plot at 22 welcome road is in the
context of other plots on the road
fairly sizable and the proposed house
does not completely fill the plot this
is not out of line with the developments
on the road i think it is hard to object
to the proposed development on the
grounds of inappropriateness for the
plot size
from my observations the gap between the
development proposed for 22 welcome road
and the neighbouring property appears
larger than the gap between some other
properties on welcome road i am
therefore quite puzzled by the comment
on discordant design which causes harm
to the street scene
and that is the end of councillor
jefferson's comments clearly i cannot
answer any questions on his behalf so we
will now move to points of clarification
to our officers councillor jennings
please
right
once a house is built
um does it need planning permission to
then put render on it
this house would yes
uh
generally speaking
houses have permitted development rights
and they include rights to improve and
alter them including using materials
that are already part of the house to
improve them
so generally speaking they could there
is a specific inclusion um in the
preliminary development right that
prevents dwelling houses on what's
described as article 2 brackets 3 land
um from using um
uh stone artificial stone pebble dash
and render to clad um
so because this house is within the
conservation area they the applicant
could not build it as per the existing
permission and then proceed to to render
it
counselor adam
thanks um
bearing in mind we are looking at the
application in front of us um how
close to the mark as it were
was the original application that this
is seeking to vary um just considering
that it was a replacement dwelling um
and this from the photo seems fairly
large essentially what i'm trying to
work out is
you notice in your report that um
there's a greater degree of harm from
from the the
the scale of it how
how much of a
impact was the original application
having that this variation is then gonna
further as you've sort of put in your
report
i think as noted on page 78 of the
agenda and my report said that this um
this section 73 application of these two
section 70 applications are comparable
to the original application reference
2101171 ful which was withdrawn as
officers were recommending refusal um
it's of a similar scale and of similar
design and that was something we were
keen to negotiate away from and um as
you can see the the image on the left is
what was approved and that's been more
acceptable
i think in that context as well it's
worth identifying the paragraph from the
nppf that's quoted on page 79 paragraph
135 which which i won't repeat but which
effectively says that the council
doesn't have to um suffer death by a
thousand cuts um you know once we've
established a permission that we think
is high quality design we are allowed to
continue to maintain a requirement for
that high quality design and
um
you know ensure that we think that uh
what we're improving through variations
is at least equally as good and in this
case we feel it falls short of that
councilcrumb
just going back to the garage
so we approved got approved permission
that
didn't
in the end meet our spd is that right
for parking so therefore that's the
reason for extending the garage
so
so i think the layout plan probably
shows that the um
parking arrangements to the front of the
house are um
fairly adequate um there is scope for
other parking elsewhere on the site
um the fact that the garage may only
have accommodated one car according to
the spd standard it probably still was
acceptable in parking terms so further
scrutiny wasn't required in that respect
castle jennings
the new ridge heights um on this
is it
does it make this house unusually high
compared to other properties down the
road
i can tell you that the ridge the gable
the right gable height would be
increased by point
six meters point five meters i don't
have a vision before me um to tell you
the comparable heights in the road i'm
afraid of dwellings thank you
so much thanks miss thanks mr chairman
um
how far is this set back from the road
again i don't have that information
before you but i can measure it for you
if you'd like is is it set back some way
sorry let me just get the um
there should be a plan that can show
that here we go
that's the proposed block plan so you
can see number 22 is in the top left
okay have we got any more questions for
our officers points clarification
no in that case let's move to debate who
would like to kick us off
council jennings
all right
well
i'm really
struggling to agree with the officer on
this one
um i don't have a problem with the
with render on houses uh it's it helps
increase the efficiency of houses modern
houses you have a house
virtually opposite it which is fully
rendered
i quite like render i'd say don't have a
problem with it
the ridge height again there are a lot
of very big houses and tall houses down
there an extra half a meter
on the right hand gable
i
i'm struggling to see the harm on that
and
again
the extra
the extra bit on the garage and to
enable two cars rather than have one car
in there and you'd be able to have one
car and a whole lot of space and then
have to park yeah the car on on the
drive it just seems slightly more
logical to me to
to allow an extra bit of
garage on it a bit of width on it as
it's such a small scale then it's so far
away from the house i'm i'm really
struggling
to go along with the officer on that one
but i welcome everyone else's thoughts
how's the candle thank you
i think i'm with council jennings
broadly on this one um i'm fairly uh
neutral on the subject of render i think
it depends on the location frankly
having seen the pictures of the uh
neighbouring houses we see uh i think
council jefferson said an eclectic mix
of render brick
throughout the area for me and i think
it's finally balanced on this but it
really does feel it's down to sort of
personal judgment on how you feel
this fits within the local vernacular
and i don't find the use of render here
to be in congress with the with the
local street scene it feels like it
would fit in quite well in terms of the
size difference it
it feels negligible i just i can't get
i'm trying to get wound up by it but i
can't it just doesn't feel big enough to
even worry about it's just so small
again in comparison to the again general
strength street scene i'm happy to
propose that we actually um grant both
of these applications
marvelous thank you very much i'm going
to call on council adam first and then i
shall say my thing
i disagree slightly well i disagree
just on the basis that
i actually touched some from the david
said in response to my question
about the increase in size i i don't
mind the actual aesthetic of it i think
that's that's something we could
probably accept
i do have a concern about the type of
application where
clearly a lot of work has gone in by the
officers and
the applicants as well to
willow down window down to a scheme
that's acceptable and then a very epic
variation application comes in to
effectively
reverse that work which is
as i was pointed out to me it's exactly
what what's being um
[Music]
seen here as far as the office is
concerned so i think that's the the
bigger concern from my point of view
and looking at them next to each other i
don't even see a major problem there but
i think actually the context of it in on
the site how it sits within the the
scene
is again the thing that is hard to grasp
from this point of view and again we
the context of this although we're
looking at the application in front of
us is it's a replacement
a replacement dwelling this is a
variation to that application not a
brand new application of itself
so on that basis alone i i don't feel i
can support this
because it it's the death by a thousand
cuts
thing that i'm concerned about and i
think that's the the thing that
although on the face of it there are
lots of things about this that are
acceptable it's the increase in volume
that that's doing it for me so i'll go
against it
um
[Music]
well we're gonna
we'll see we've we've already got our
proposals you can make a proposal now if
you want to so you can make proposals
going along with the doctor's
recommendation we'll see if someone
seconds it
i'll i'll do that then i thought good
man okay um does anyone else want
something before i do
councilman just a quick one uh mr
chairman yeah i mean i have to agree
with both uh council kendall
councillor jennings on this one uh there
it is a mishmash
of uh designs along there and there are
quite a few rendered properties so um
i will go get yourself this
recommendation on this mr chairman thank
you
cancer crump yeah i'll just come in
briefly it's it's quite a tricky one um
you know
there's a phrase beauties in the eye of
the beholder and sometimes people think
this is wonderful and other people
will think the opposite
i think it's a question of
do do the changes
materially diminish the
the approval
i'm not i'm not i'm not sure what they
do i am
this is the most difficult one tonight
on the agenda i feel
um and i didn't think it would be when i
first saw it so
this is
causing me some angst um i would like to
hear what you've got to say as well um
but
this is in the balance for me this is
not as clear-cut as i originally thought
it was going to be
okay my turn um
i find myself in a very strange
situation where i agree with
pretty much everybody including
counselor adam um you made some points i
was going to make uh earlier on i am
going to second counselor kendall's uh
proposal
um i'm not a fan of render personally
but i can understand why other people
might be clearly in this area there are
plenty of examples of either fully
rendered properties or partially
rendered properties so to refuse on that
basis i think would be uh entirely wrong
um
i actually prefer the design of this uh
variation i think i i i'm trying to get
some advice i don't know what you'd call
those windows at the front i think
they're hipped um above the garage in
the lower left-hand floor window i
prefer that design from
uh the one that we're looking at on the
left
in terms of the sizing
this is where i'm starting to agree with
cancer adam
0.6 of a meter in height and i think
there's a little bit of extension to the
sides as well
in the scheme of things is negligible
could be considered to be negligible but
when you start adding that 0.6 to
another 0.6 to another 0.6 suddenly it
becomes a problem and it does become
death by a thousand cuts
i wouldn't want to see this go any
bigger than it currently is
if it does i would be minded to agree
that the volume is getting too big but
in its current form i think i'm
satisfied that this would fit
comfortably within the plot and within
the street scene without causing any
material
harm to that street scene
so on that basis and for those reasons
i'm going to be seconding now we've had
a proposal uh to grant it's been
seconded we have had a proposal to
refuse i will put it out there if anyone
wants to second that proposal it will of
course we'll have to hear the grant
first would anyone like to second that
no okay are you satisfied that you've
got enough from us for reasons to go
against the recommendation yes thank you
okay
um we need to talk about conditions
do you have a
list i have a list of 17 conditions
these are in line with the the full
permission um
the first condition would be three years
from the date of the original permission
being granted which is the 10th of
november 2021.
the condition two would obviously be
changed to be in accordance with the
plans approved under the section 73
applications
um condition three i've written to amend
to be in accordance with details is
approved under
discharge of conditions application
which was recently approved um for the
full permission
um the other conditions are all in line
with um
the previous consent for the full
permission for the replacement dwelling
at the site
um
um
have you got any other conditions you'd
like to add in no i'm happy with those
i'm happy with those as well okay um in
that case i think we're we're okay to go
to a boat aren't we
so the proposal is to grant uh for the
reasons that we have given with the
conditions that we've just given could i
please have a show of hands for those in
favor
six and those against
one therefore committee resolves to
grant uh application twenty one zero
three nine five two very and
do we have to take them
you take one separately brilliant we can
take them on block so and twenty two
zero zero five five two very um
brilliant we have as far as i know no
urgent business in which case it remains
for me to thank you all uh for your time
contributions this evening and of course
members of the public that have joined
us as well
thank you everyone we'll see you next
time